In today's video,
we're going to see what happens
if we take 100 pounds of dry ice,
and pour it all into a hot tub at once.
[Music]
Recently, we tried pouring
dry ice into boiling water,
and we got a really cool effect,
and we thought we
should scale that up.
So now, instead
of a pot of water,
we're going to use
a full running hot tub.
We're going to pour
some dry ice into it.
But like so much more.
This is almost
my body weight in dry ice.
One thing we do want to try,
we discovered we got
a much cooler reaction
if some of our dry ice
was really smashed up
and sort of powderized.
So we're going to break a bunch
of this dry ice up,
and we're going to keep a bunch
of large size lumps,
and then I think we're going
to need a hot tub.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and put some in a bag,
so I can smash it with a hammer!
[Music]
Rubber gloves may not have
been the best choice.
[Music]
We've got 100 pounds
of crushed up dry ice.
I think at this point,
we need a hot tub.
We should be in a hot tub.
Hey internet.
Guess what?
For the next two weeks,
we're having a sweet sale
on t-shirts, both this one,
and the "Look Mom,
No hands" for only $19.99.
What are you doing?
Selling T-shirts.
I have to go.
Click the link
in the description below.
Guys, we are going
to take our mics off now,
so the sound will get
a little bit different.
We-- Our mics aren't waterproof,
and we don't want
to ruin our equipment.
So we're just going to be using
the mic attached to the camera.
Okay, we've got
100 pounds of dry ice.
We've divided it up
into three buckets.
Cali's going to take one.
I'm going to take one,
and my friend Keith here
is going to help as well.
Keith will be pouring
dry ice in.
We should be pouring
a hundred-pound--
Probably a little
more than a hundred pounds,
because they're not super
accurate when they're weighing
at the grocery stores.
It's probably more
like 11/10, 1/15,
something like that.
But all off this dry ice
are gonna get poured in at once.
I'm hoping for a giant cloud.
Are you?
Yes.
Okay.
I mean, we're going
to just then be in the cloud,
and hopefully, not asphyxiate,
but it's fine.
I can hold my breath.
All right, who's counting?
Ready?
3, 2,1.
That's so amazing.
Oh no.
Oh, that broke.
Oh no! Oh, it's burning my feet.
Don't stand on it.
No, it's burning
my feet you guys.
Oh, it's like moving
around in there.
Yeah.
[Music]
No, no, no.
It's like boiling
out everywhere.
Oh, my foot.
What?
Guys, this is insane.
Should we pour in some
liquid nitrogen while we're at it?
Oh yeah.
This is like the bubble feature
without the bubbles.
Dry ice, it hurts.
This was only up
to my thighs before.
I'm soaked from the waist down.
It's like floating up
and then sinking again.
I got one.
Pass it.
I threw it on the ground.
I just want everyone to know
that I forgot to bring
a second pair of pants.
I'm driving home like this.
Carbon dioxide is cool,
but since we're
pouring stuff in,
we're gonna pour in some liquid
nitrogen along with it.
I don't like it.
I don't want it.
I don't wanna.
Too bad.
That cooled the water
down significantly.
It is no longer a hot tub.
I'm going to regret this.
You cannot breathe in there.
Oh no.
Not with that attitude.
Oh, hey!
I found a camera.
It was over here.
That's gonna be a fun video.
I'm just gonna throw
it back down in there.
Yep.
Let it do it's thing.
Time to vote, who wins
the wet t-shirt contest?
Mine's wetter, I win.
I found the GoPro again.
Let's get this shot.
Where are you?
It's like a submarine.
It's like at a Star Wars.
Oh, yeah.
R2D2 and it's Mom.
Yeah, R2D2 and it's Mom.
If you've ever opened up
like a really big bottle,
or a really fizzy 2 liter soda,
and just like put your nose
right over the bottle
and breathe in.
Don't breathe.
Just--
It's smells like
kind of like that,
but like times a thousand.
This is no longer a hot tub.
It says it's down 96,
that's 8 degrees cooler.
I think it's actually
colder than that.
In case anyone wondering,
this will also be
my audition reel
for the Little Mermaid.
[Music]
Okay, I don't recommend this,
but holding it under the water
makes it easier to hold.
That's amazing.
This is actually
interesting how quickly,
we've now gone through almost
all that dry ice.
We've kind of been tossing it
into this corner over here,
and this handful represents
about 90% of what's left.
You can actually
hear the bubbles.
Including the GoPro,
which is not dry ice.
The shocking part is yes,
the water temperature
has lowered significantly,
but it's still pretty warm,
and we dumped 100 pounds
of dry ice and liquid nitrogen
in here with us.
So, not bad.
Oh wait, there's...
Look at these
little tiny survivors.
The ones floating on the hood?
Yeah.
Oh hey!
Another GoPro.
[Music]
It's carbonated!
A little bit,
and as it's gross,
there's people sit in this.
So we put dry ice in our gloves.
With some water.
[Music]
It's really cool.
Guys, this has been awesome.
Are there any other experiments
that you want to see
us do with dry ice,
or a hot tub?
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
This bomb in the middle
will subscribe to our channel,
that way, you'll never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.